hey everybody its charlie there was just
a big venom preview that they dropped so
I'm gonna break this down top-10 style
they talked about carnage I know
everybody has crazy carnage questions so
no worries but if you're brand new to
the channel there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway I'll
explain at the end of the video so be
sure to subscribe to get everything but
starting with number 10 Tom Hardy is
signed for three films he confirmed that
they did plan to do sequels we knew that
they would try to do at least one sequel
but trilogy is a much bigger thing and
they've already set up what their sequel
is going to be so I'll explain that it's
also on my list here but the movie will
set up its own sequel so definitely be
sure to stay through the credits 9 he's
not signed up for any of the
spider-verse spin-off films that they're
developing so that includes Morbius the
living vampire the black cat movie
silver sable the Kraven the hunter movie
spider-man silk the jackpot movie in the
Nightwatch movie there are a lot of Sony
spider-verse movies that they have
planned pretty safe to say that not all
those are eventually gonna get made some
of them for sure but Tom Hardy said that
they're just waiting to see how venom
does and how the scripts turn out for
these other films before signing him up
for a billion other films because venom
is the big attraction don't be surprised
if some of these other characters pop up
in the venom sequels stealing a page at
a Kevin Feige of spider-man playbook
would do them a lot of good eight there
are a lot of Easter eggs and a lot of
characters from the spider-man comics
but this is supposed to be a standalone
film it's not connected to the MCU at
least that's the way that they shot it I
already did a big video after Comic Con
about the earlier comments you may
remember Tom Hardy is not my daddy's
tractor at the end of day that's that's
that's core never book my Pike right now
so it's not my daddy's tractor now that
being said what they are confirming is
is that everybody's open to legit Tom
Horne crossover because Tom Holland has
said he wants to crossover with venom in
venom Tom Hardy has said that he wants
to crossover with Tom Horne
but because so many lawyers are involved
and it gets so complicated because of
what Marvel is doing with MCU spider-man
which is way too much for right now but
we do get into sequel talk with
so I'll explain but you know about
spider-man and how he figures into these
venom sequels seven Michelle Williams
who's playing an waying who's Eddie
Brock's girlfriend in the movie ex-wife
in the comics was asked point-blank if
she's gonna get the symbiote in the
future because there was a she venom Ark
like she was just called she venom she
got really excited and talked about how
cool it would be to do something like
that which pretty much confirms that
she's just a totally normal person in
this first movie so if they do go
full-blown she venom in a sequel it
would probably be just like they did it
in the comics a very temporary situation
whereby she got shot by the Sin Eater
was bleeding out the Venom symbiote
bonded with her to save her life then
once there was no more danger to her
life the Venom symbiote left it's kind
of like Pepper Potts and her rescued on
armor not something that she flies
around in all the time but every once in
a while like Iron Man 3 she gets to
briefly wear the costume we actually do
have Pepper Potts rescued on stuff
happening in Avengers 4 but we haven't
actually seen footage of that yet just
her in a motion capture outfit like oh
yeah you are definitely wearing some
armor here we can talk more about that
in a Marvel MCU Avengers video speaking
of motion capture though 6 the symbiote
in the movie is not motion capture Tom
Hardy was like literally walking around
with his street clothes on
they just artfully placed the Venom
symbiote in post-production on top of
them even though that sounds like motion
capture when he says they didn't do
mocap he's mostly talking about his
facial expressions because he said that
Venom's face and the eyes don't move
like a natural humans like humans don't
unhinge their jaws to buy people's heads
off so it just didn't make sense for
them to shoot it the same way they shoot
Mark Ruffalo's hoax scenes or Tom
Hollands Avengers infinity war iron
spider scenes because that's all mopey
flike full CG spider-man and all these
big fight scenes 5 this is actually kind
of funny he said that his Eddie Brock
performance and his venom performances
especially the venom voice were inspired
by a couple different things one Woody
Allen's neuroses so that's like when
he's walking down the street talking to
himself but he's really talking to the
Venom symbiote looking like a total
crazy person that's him going full-blown
Woody Allen that this is even better
the venom influences for the venom voice
and the physicality the way venom moves
were Redman Buster rhymes in James Brown
he said
went to them mostly for the way that
they move in the way they talked just
because the venom character needs to be
larger than life and move in such a much
more expressive way than someone like
Eddie Brock moves number four main
villain Carlton Drake's whole thing is
that he's like an evil Tony Stark or a
more insidious version of Norman Osborn
a scientist trying to save all the
world's problems as he sees them without
any real sense of morality so he sees
the world crumbling around him he has
that speech in the trailer about
everything falling apart he wants to
forcibly evolve the human race when the
symbiotes mysteriously fall into his lap
crash landing to earth in that
spacecraft so I know everybody that saw
that Ryan Reynolds movie life about the
astronauts to find that alien parasite
that then kills them all and crash lands
their spaceship down to earth thinks
that's a venom prequel it's not supposed
to be but funny enough that's basically
the story of how the symbiotes in the
venom movie make it to planet Earth they
fully hijack the situation to crash-land
the spacecraft to Planet Earth because
they're part of the Clint are their
whole thing is spread and destroy take
over think of it as like the aliens in
the alien movies where their whole life
mission is just to propagate like it's
not like they're gonna start writing
poetry or gardening or anything like
that
they find hosts they propagate they find
more hosts for those new symbiotes so on
so forth as they slowly spread out
across the universe so words is just the
latest destination in the Clint ARS
galactic conquest 3 riot the main evil
symbiote is the ringleader he's gonna be
the main villain the big bad when he
binds with carlton drake during the film
but the symbiotes have their own
internal power dynamic venom is supposed
to be the runt of the litter as Tom
Hardy talks about him the underdog who
doesn't want to have anything to do with
the other symbiotes not because he as
part of the Clint are race wants to save
planet Earth is just that he doesn't
want to be a lackey or a whipping boy to
the other symbiotes anymore so he hates
the out of the riot symbiote while
Tom Hardy is trying to stop Carlton
Drake's character in the easiest way to
accomplish their goals is to kill both
of those people kill the riots symbiote
kill Carlton Drake so you've already
seen a lot of those scenes in the
trailer where they're going at each
other just ripping each other apart
number 2 of course the interviewer was
asking them all about carnage
the director said this is actually kind
of funny the fans should be excited
quote-unquote to go see the film to see
if he's in it which basically confirms
that he's in it because if you were
director trying to hype up a film you
wouldn't say that Oh carnage you like
him well you'll be excited to go see if
he's in the movie wink wink if you knew
that people would be disappointed if he
wasn't in the movie so just a reminder
the carnage is not a main character
during this film he's basically setting
up the sequel so just a small tag like
oh wow he exists meaning that's what our
second film is gonna be so number one
the sequels venom versus carnage pretty
easy pitch carnage is crazy way crazier
than the riot symbiote it'd be like
going from a lawful evil say like Thanos
to chaotic evil Norman Osborn full-blown
crazy Green Goblin meanie that number
three the third film of the trilogy will
probably be their maximum carnage big
crossover epic event because maximum
carnage is just the most notable carnage
story you would probably save that for
your closer so that would involve some
sort of crossover with other characters
from the Sony spider-verse
and maybe their opportunity for a Peter
Parker spider-man inclusion because
think about it this way but six years
before that third film would happen by
that time we'll have our third MCU
spider-man film and our fifth Avengers
film meaning that Marvel would have had
this really big long run of awesome
spider-man Tom Holland films so I think
if everything works out with the venom
franchise then the Sony and Marvel
people will be much more open to letting
Tom Hall and crossover with venom but
remember that third film wouldn't happen
for another six years so that's way down
the road anything can change between now
and then but that's when I would expect
to see spider-man crossover everyone
just pray that they rescind that sharing
arrangement with Marvel and Kevin Feige
so everything works out down the road
but there is a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video congratulations to the winner from
my last big video Ammar and a pot up
please email me on the about page of my
youtube channel so I can get your
contact details click here for that new
spider-man far from home avengers Easter
Egg and click here to rewatch the venom
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
I'll see you
tonight
[Music]